i feel like people are in gangs you
should be able to
give yourself a chance in life because
life is short and you can look up and
that's that's one thing i told myself i
just don't want to have no regrets
knowing that i didn't give myself a
chance you know and if something was to
go left or right at least i could say i
tried you know so i feel like every
other person that's dealing with those
situations give yourself a chance
[Music]
hello everybody can you believe it i'm
still here that's right on this rooftop
living in the tent for 100 days from
november 20th to february 28th bringing
attention and awareness to the violence
in chicago but most of all trying to
build a community center and raise
enough funds to have it built on this
block that they call o block it's called
o block named after a young man named od
perry who was shot and killed the gangs
picked up his name and started calling
it o block we decided to keep the o
because we like the o but we're going to
call it opportunity block and today on
rooftop revelations i'm so excited to
have one of our poster children one of
our models for what we're trying to do
with brothers from our community i have
devin howard here today uh to talk about
his accomplishments his success his
struggles
uh i am thankful for you being here man
thank you listen when it comes to our
construction in trades
we tell everybody
the example that we want you to follow
is devin howard
oh appreciate it absolutely absolutely
can you just tell people for a moment a
little bit about yourself your
background okay um hi guys my name is
devin howard um so i started out
attended murray language academy in the
hyde park area
lived out on 83rd and uh damon for a
little while then i ended up moving to
84th and paxton
ended up going to urban prep inglewood
played a little bit of high school
football once i graduated graduated
2017.
had a great gpa 3.8 gpa
made the last minute choice to go to
college attending eastern illinois and
i was playing football out there and
taking up nursing as a major and i came
to realization i didn't like nursing
and
while i was there i started realizing
like certain things that just wasn't
falling in line with myself and i was
just feeling more so i wasn't
comfortable
going to school i wasn't thinking as i
wasn't good at school but it was more so
as a
i didn't i wasn't feeling like it was
for me myself so i started picking up
books um
reading different books here and there
on financial literacy and
first book i picked up was rich dad poor
dad and john c maxwell's seven laws of
leadership
after that i i decided you know what
it's time to give school to quit
dropped out and i decided to go sign up
for the navy
sitting there on the titan title for a
little minute um contemplating if i want
to go to the navy and
i came to like my shipping date and when
my shipping day came i backed out
i backed out you know so i started
thinking about looking up i was starting
investigating warships and different
things going on and you know what i
started picking up
hands-on things such as real estate and
carpentry and painting i started falling
in love with those things when my mom
been in real estate for a minute and you
know i somewhat leaned on her and i
watched her and i started thinking you
know how can i provide
generational wealth for my family and
for myself and i was like you know i'm
gonna take on real estate and some type
of hands-on that could provide a trade
i'm sitting around for a little minute i
received a real estate license my mom
called me she told me about the
carpentry program
i somewhat thought about i said i'm
gonna think about it next you know she's
like you know you're not doing anything
right now the real estate hasn't really
picked up yet let's take one let's take
it on and she was right you know time is
your biggest commodity i'm just sitting
around wasting time joined the program
man man it was a big change you know um
i met a lot of new faces and people from
different backgrounds and it helped me
realize that not all of us had the same
circumstances you know um and to
appreciate what we have and i'll be
honest with you
i built like a family and a friendship
with some of those students and i still
talk to them till this day you know
check in on some of them here and there
on facebook and i stay in contact but
while i was in the program
i met a gentleman by the name of bill
and
as you know um deal provided he works
for reconstruction he's the ceo of
reconstruction
he provided me a business card that day
and that day i it was a year from later
kobe came around i left
and i just i just said forget it you
know i don't know what's going on i'm
probably not going to stick with it a
year later bill reached out to me
offering me a position with the company
as a project engineer
so from that point on it's just been
it's been great great opportunities
right so here you are
growing up in the neighborhood um
going to school figuring out hey that's
maybe not what i want to do
and you tried real estate and but you
ended up in our construction class
you were the top student in our
construction class you did everything
that we needed you to do you went
through all the trainings got the
certifications
and you ended up
at a major construction company
absolutely
doing being a project manager yeah
so so
tell us about that what is your what
what does your job entail now so um i'm
more so i manage project sites okay um
i go to different projects i'm dealing
with some in deerfield we're currently
dealing with the project on 83rd and
cottage the discovery project
i more so manage and make sure
everything is in line as far as from
material um
submittals to making sure the schedule
is on point providing weekly reports to
the client so it's a make it's basically
the tail that's keeping the project
managers up to date making sure
everything fall in line so
it's it's more so in office it's not in
the field right you're still
on that project from start to finish so
you have to be
detailed knowing what every
subcontractor is at and what's the
status of every project so
so you know
the community you know our construction
program
how beneficial do you think it would be
for a lot of the guys who are in gangs
who
who have lost their way
maybe some have come home from jail
how beneficial do you think it would be
for them to be in a trades program
like the one we offer at project hood it
would be it would be great um it would
be definitely beneficial it will open
expand many horizons um a lot a lot of i
know for myself personal friends haven't
left at least the four blocks going east
west north and south you know some never
seen downtown and when i when i can see
some of their reactions when i expose
them to some of the things that i've
done already and it's not like nothing
major to me but when i see their
expression right it's it gives me a
happy feeling inside because it's like
you know
i know i've experienced this before but
seeing you for the first time and this
is what it feels like man i wish i could
do this for the next person over and
over and over again you know so i feel
like people that ain't gained you should
be able to
give yourself a chance in life because
life is short and you can look up and
that's that's one thing i told myself i
just don't have no regrets knowing that
i didn't give myself a chance you know
and if something was to go left or right
at least i could say i tried you know so
i feel like every other person that's
dealing with those situations give
yourself a chance absolutely well man i
want to tell you we appreciate you
uh we we we appreciate your journey your
success
and uh we want you to continue to strive
and go higher and higher continue to be
an example for project hood and all that
we're trying to accomplish and and thank
you for coming to rooftop revelations
and being out here in this cold weather
in chicago it is it's right it's real
cold so listen it's been a blessing and
i want to thank all of you thanks to fox
for giving us this opportunity to give
you rooftop revelations every single day
and as i always say i'll see you
tomorrow peace
you